yeah welcome to this video and we got
five minutes action again when I CC
playing the pills against FM corners
nokomis from Norway and the Bishop e3
line which I of course completely forgot
ok c 6 b 5 SF a way to to play Queen a
five if I remember correctly it's also
possible okay let's play this first and
see what he comes up with the FF 3m
let's compete five
so a five now yeah I probably need to
need to to cover it
you're this doesn't look too bad i am
quite like it then d5 something like h4
really s is nonsense in this position
I've got big counter play already on
there in the center so what now is Queen
B 6 completely ridiculous oh wait what
about c5 just really really opening up
the center why not why not
no reason not to I guess
so taking on d4 and rookie one's an idea
a row create of course trying to
irritate his King in the middle okay so
95 simply 95 Bishop before but I have
Bishop be self or is there something
different
I can take the form of course yeah maybe
no big reason not to d5 is still can't
still on pre entere thought queen bee 60
intending d3 would be rather knowing how
maybe maybe it is no threat should I
take it anyway yeah probably and now
just take you five yo it's just an extra
phone is there some trick night f5 still
it's only your check it's still only a
check Roxy 6 Roxy 6 this is a nasty move
mmhmm yeah I can't play this anyway and
Luke c6 Queen a7 hanging on to the pawn
I don't see a big counter play now with
the bishop on CH controlling f5 those
night at five ideas are also under under
lock and key and wow 57 where do you go
after Bishop d7
57
I want to go rook e8 real badly yep get
to his king
so yeah take you
so is there be six or something
threatened what about
yeah b6 v6s slightly slightly annoying
25 maybe just attacking it and I'm
threatening b5
yes maybe this was good I don't know
he's got not quite sure what white is
playing now I taking of one I take be
five with checks on and I just threaten
to take g6 of course so the different
difficult for him to move I don't really
see him a kinky one
you may be king ah yeah okay taking was
check cannot be too bad yeah trick and
now
Knight f6 he can play Knight f6 Jesus
night if sticks can't believe it what
did I want now let's grab it the damn
time yeah
check
ah what the game check check
yeah losing is really ridiculous time
warning check
check
check
check check check
check okay I've come on i played this on
time no I don't mind yeah I have a
history with this guy yeah like four
things on time so um before you start to
blame me for playing on time I know that
this guy is playing one time was it all
the time so i won't give it to give it
anything here and besides of course the
position was was utterly winning I
somehow bungled this up him yeah I can
just I can just take you for him hiru ka
tu su winning funny enough but ok bye
now I had completely lost the thread ok
check check check yeah 94 I didn't see
that I can just retreat to have six if
it takes d4 with check it's everything
everything's covered until this means
this is really easy just just take here
alright thanks for watching